hello and welcome to this video playing
Lilliput eighty-eight and below 2,400
again yeah it happens if you play
cheaters and then blunder the house in
the next game why didn't that takes is
six what Wow
that was far too routine what I did
that's a bit of a pain you know just you
just gifted me the game you know I just
didn't pay any attention we really did
g6 here I can take the 6th and black
resigns you know okay so anyway let's
play the game
97 okay I'm running into 95 come on
focus 97 was not about just about 95 but
also about this move we can now have to
answer was something that I did not
intend beforehand not certain that it is
so bad but it was not planned wasn't
planned
oh they bent the cheetah already it was
quick it was quick
okay so Quinta c8 um why is that a moose
got 95 here he might take with the Queen
it doesn't really look a lot great not
sure if the guys watching see that
probably only is the other guys he's
that right I'm not really informed them
he refund six blitz rating points right
and these dead works I mean if you
report somebody and it's completely
obvious and sometimes really they they
settle this quite quickly
I honestly think I'm quite amazed
sometimes that people can I mean he had
this high rating 2600 so it took some
games to get down and I mean don't
people report I mean I understand that
you shouldn't like report every single
game where you feel like a.m. that was
all or something but if it's so
blatantly obvious you just have to bend
the hell out of them and report report
report so um what's going on here
do I want to trade Queens not really am
the knight on c4 is is strong I don't
want to trade Queens I rather want to
attack his weaknesses here like f5 so
let's go I go here it's not the most
natural square h5 is maybe more more
obvious but I went here because the
Queen is covered so that if he goes the
Queen g-form
then it's not a tempo that it is a tempo
Ani - actually yeah which is not super
important so what do we do here b3 I
don't really mind if he takes it - I
would like to prevent him from going
Knights you form Queen e2 I just take f5
that is excellent for white
and maybe had something better than beef
B 3 it's a bit of an odd move never I
don't think it's it's it should be ok
really he I don't see it a good tempo
with the night and if he just has to
play this position it's totally rotten
ok but should be salmon was stronger I
just wanted to get out of this but what
good move does he have here there's just
no good move yeah this is this the next
problem black's pawn structure is really
the absolute worst yep
take it ok the bishop here is covering
covering c2 which is really nice just
wonder
it's got Knight f3 check it's not not a
dramatic problem but ok let's not allow
it with the check yeah I was thinking
about this move I mean I can take g6 and
take d6 but it's not
huh it's not what you weren't ready
hmm I am okay never move my light
squared Bishop and that's also not
making much sense so let's say that
let's grab this my idea was that this is
almost a temple but it is not a temple
[Music]
shoot bad claim I did not play that
right did not play that right Shh b6 was
a lot stronger you should have gone b6
I mean it was too bad from for him but
not Wow and what still was badly
converted really badly converted so I
think here black should be completely
fine him with with something I don't
know with with what exactly but okay the
engine gives Knight to g4 or Lucas II
AIDS it must be fine I don't think my
play can be that great here with all the
Queen moves yeah I mean okay the game I
could just takes his six year I mean I
just didn't pay any attention that was a
bad thing anyway so we were him and he
played an n95 is just excellent John
Quincy for I'm just a bit I'm curious
about the technical phase of the game so
this must be right
Queen g5 I think should be okay Quinn
yeah it's it's one of the top choices
and here I'm not sure about b3 yet it's
not a bad move I believe but maybe it's
not the best b3 inaccuracy but it keeps
a clear advantage Jim yeah if I'm like
1.7 I'm fine
the engine wants to take only two hmm I
thought I can just take f5 and I'm just
hugely better and I am okay so he traded
damn look q1 f6 yeah okay it's it's a
very good pollution and King g2 is
probably wrong that is the wrong move
the computer wants to go Bishop to be
one yeah I should just like step out of
this step out of this this discovery so
that after some move like that I can I
can keep my bishop I mean that's not
good 96 but the way it was I needed to
do something that was undesirable I
didn't want to take on g6 or now you can
also think about retreating the bishop I
mean why does of course clearly better
here but that is not the best possible
outcome and the way it turned out I
really got into some issues in Bishop e7
not the best move you know and he should
definitely play here instead of this go
b6 I thought wait here b6 b6 bishop
deform and then take here I thought but
rook c1 and it's still bad from lucky I
just a very bad position even my
blunders didn't help you know the way it
turned out
you just couldn't couldn't hold it yeah
Bishop h6 does not help but it just
makes it's no big difference yeah you
just cannot cannot repair the same once
the structure is so bad as it is here it
takes
yeah material blunders that save to get
in to get back into the game for black
yeah thanks a lot for watching